entre 100 et 150 personnes ont manifesté
aujourd'hui dans les rues de la capitale
pour porter les revendications qui sont
celles d'un gilet jaune depuis près de
deux ans maintenant à savoir donc une
justice sociale justice fiscale l'accent
a également été mis sur les taxes sur
les produits de première nécessité c'est
ce qui apparaît en tout cas dans la
déclaration
cette manifestation aujourd'hui
manifestation en forme de répétition
nous explique les gilet jaune puisqu'il
vise désormais la rentrée le mois de
septembre une rentrée qui s'annonce
chargée avec notamment une date celle du
12 septembre où un appel à la
mobilisation nationale a été lancé par
plusieurs groupes de gilet jaune ainsi
que par d'autres organisations
écoutez à ce sujet de gilet jaune que
nous avons pu interroger avant le départ
de cette manifestation aujourd'hui la
rentrée sera quand même très très
revendicatif
il ya des préoccupations qu'attendent
les français aujourd'hui c'est comment
vivre dignement et on a toujours demandé
qu' un grenelle du poids d'achat qui
soit fait un bond à un grenelle 3
d'achat et économiques et fiscales qui
sont organisées par l'état pour savoir
si aujourd'hui avec son salaire on peut
vivre dignement et la rentrée scolaire
aujourd'hui lorsque les gens ont vu que
le coût que ça va coûter la rentrée
scolaire les obligations qui vont devoir
avoir de façon à assurer la
distanciation sociale sans doute le
vaccin obligatoire
l'isolément des enfants il ya beaucoup
de chose qu'est ce que ce passé à la
rentrée scolaire
il peut y avoir une seconde colère une
deuxième vague qui peut venir d'un
peuple en colère sur ce côté obligations
répression et soumission on dit qu'il ya
la seconde vague du corps il va y avoir
la seconde vague gilet jaune
le hashtag de septembre et
on voit encore comme vous le dites ici
y'a pas grand monde mais après maints
peu de monde pour une période de
vacances et ouais c'est une date très
importante ça va montrer le
mécontentement de la population
comme on peut le voir en ce moment c'est
délicat dans notre pays est lui-même les
personnalités si m quand on voit jean
marie bigard qui a aussi fait un appel à
être le hashtag 12 septembre lui-même à
aux côtés de jérôme rodriguez et oui
c'est ivoire du mouvement dans le début
de septembre pendant la rentrée par des
manifestations qui a donc été déclaré et
approuvé par la préfecture de police de
paris qui a recommandé le port du masque
ainsi que le respect de la distanciation
physique à noter enfin qu'un important
dispositif de sécurité a été déployé
avec de très nombreux crs qui ont
véritablement encadrer ce cortège ce
samedi après midi au point même pendant
que sur les images on a l'impression
parfois qu'il ya autant de forces de
l'ordre déployées aujourd'hui que deux
participants à la manifestation